[Música]
hay frases que aún no lo marcan y cuando
uno está rodeado de niños
esto sucede casi a diario hay una en
particular que me inspira mucho en la
naturaleza sólo hay cosas bonitas no
seas lo digo julieta una niña de cuatro
años y creo que repito ese sentido
metafórico poético tan lindo de los
niños todos los niños nacen con un amor
profundo por la naturaleza todos todos
nacen con un pensamiento muy similar el
de julieta porque instintivamente se
reconocen como parte de ella vivimos en
interdependencia si los niños aman la
naturaleza desde que nacen porque es que
de adultos a tanto se nos olvida
cuidarla amarla protegerla y eso me lo
pregunto constantemente cuando ve a
alguien tirar una basura por el carro o
que simplemente deja algo tirado en la
calle o que quiere matar a todos los
insectos que se encuentran
los vínculos de los niños con la
naturaleza están fuertemente
influenciados por nuestros
comportamientos como adultos lo que
decimos lo que hacemos lo que les
permitimos o no y no estoy hablando
solamente de padres de familia sino de
educadores de tíos abuelos ciudadanos en
general
básicamente el que los niños a mí la
naturaleza la cuiden y por lo tanto a
nosotros también depende de nuestras
acciones y por eso mi intención hoy es
compartirles porque es vital porque
debería ser un derecho que todos los
niños crezcan rodeados de naturaleza que
puedan aprender con la naturaleza qué
acciones concretas podemos llevar a cabo
y qué consecuencias hay si no lo hacemos
entonces yo también les quiero preguntar
en ya que acaban de llegar del almuerzo
levantando la mano entendiendo que hay
tantas tantas personas hoy para cuántos
de ustedes los mejores recuerdos de
infancia sucedieron en la naturaleza si
pueden levantar la mano
es muy emocionante ver desde aquí a
tantas tantas personas que tienen este
vínculo hay una una realidad compartida
para muchos de nosotros para casi todos
aquí la naturaleza y la infancia están
de la mano por eso creo que muchas de
las ideas que les voy a contar les van a
resonar
cuando para un niño o una niña una
cuesta una piedra o un charco en el
camino no son obstáculos como lo pueden
ser para la mayoría de adultos sino que
son oportunidades para conocer las
posibilidades de su cuerpo poder moverse
poder subirse a un árbol para
desarrollar la auto confianza es decir
creer en sí mismos y por supuesto para
jugar en la naturaleza está magia de los
niños debe existir para siempre cuando
uno está frente a una escena como esta y
puede hacer ayer que estaba lloviendo y
ve a los niños en los charcos brincando
felices no sé que ustedes les pasa pero
para mí hay algo dentro de mí que me
jala que me invita que me mueve a
meterme en ese charco y mi hipótesis es
que esto sucede porque este pensamiento
o este recuerdo no me llega solamente al
cerebro sino que lo siento en todo mi
cuerpo hay una necesidad de conectar con
esa niña interior hay una necesidad de
volver a vivir esas experiencias
de infancia plenamente y esos recuerdos
los siguen creando los niños desde
pequeños y les cuento este ejemplo de
gabriel gabriel tiene 12 meses y él
practica diariamente con gran esfuerzo y
determinación el arte de caminar por la
vida gracias a sus inmensas capacidades
de exploración a una educación que
valora el tiempo lento de la infancia y
a su posibilidad de moverse libremente
gabriel encuentra este árbol
él entiende que este árbol es sólido por
lo que le va a brindar estabilidad lo va
a [ __ ] porque sensorialmente es muy
rico y proyectó una energía muy positiva
y le va a brindar estabilidad y
confianza porque está ahí para él y lo
espera para gabriel a sus doce meses el
árbol y él son uno es como si fuera una
extensión de su cuerpo
la maestra competente acompañó este niño
lo escucha le brinda el espacio y el
tiempo pero sobre todo confía en él y en
la naturaleza
cómo sería la experiencia aprender a
caminar fuera de la naturaleza
seguramente sería en un lugar plano como
suavecito con estas alfombras que hacen
para que los niños no se caigan y les
pase nada
como un libro de obstáculos con un
adulto que está dándole la mano todo el
tiempo o que está casi que encima de él
para evitar que se caiga o que se metan
a algo a la boca es una experiencia
mucho más limitante pero los niños nos
sorprenden porque son capaces porque se
retan continuamente porque tienen una
necesidad tan grande que satisfacer de
autonomía y de aprendizaje y saben
porque también porque se caen y se
levantan tantas tantas veces y ese poder
tan grande el mejor escenario para
hacerlo es en la naturaleza
hay muchos estudios que fundamentan que
crecer rodeado de naturaleza y aprender
con la naturaleza es muy importante es
muy poderoso lo primero es que se
sienten más felices más plenos menos
estresados menos violentos menos
ansiosos más en calma para mí ya eso es
todo si tuviera que decirles una cosa de
un beneficio la naturaleza esa calma y
esa felicidad de verdad que para mí ya
esto
y también hay otros beneficios muy
importantes para el desarrollo integral
de los niños como por ejemplo que
mejoran los patrones de sueño o sea
duermen mejor y también que hay una
mejora en su sistema inmunológico es
buenísimo comer tierra es buenísimo
andar descalzos
aprender con la naturaleza y aprender en
la naturaleza es muy muy poderoso porque
desarrolla la autoconfianza la
colaboración la empatía la resolución de
problemas complejos el manejo de sus
emociones el manejo del riesgo 5 de
estas habilidades pertenecen al grupo
que el foro económico mundial determina
como las 10 habilidades necesarias para
la vida y el trabajo en el 2020 creo que
es algo de lo que está los otros
expositores también han comentado pero
la naturaleza realmente es poderosa y
les cuento un dato muy curioso y muy
impactante
los niños actualmente pasan en promedio
menos tiempo en espacios exteriores que
un privado de libertad pueden crearlo
los niños pasan menos tiempo en espacios
exteriores que un privado de libertad
cuando antes uno más bien esperaba lo
hasta lo más tarde en la aldea y me
acuerdo que me decían a mi canal y de
nada que ya sé eso es de noche que te
metes a la casa ahora los niños hay que
así que empujarlos para que salgan y por
eso por esto este dato que les estoy
diciendo es que muchos niños están
viviendo el llamado trastorno por
déficit de naturaleza esta es una meta
fuera propuesta por richard luz que
habla de la lejanía de los niños con la
naturaleza y quiere decir que entre más
alejados están los niños de la
naturaleza y los adultos más
desconectados están de sí mismos de las
personas y más riesgo tienen de afectar
su salud física y mental es realmente
preocupante no queremos que esto pase
si queremos conservacionistas de corazón
no hay papel no de título de corazón
necesitamos devolverle a los niños el
tiempo en la naturaleza si esta
generación la de hoy de niños pierde el
contacto con la naturaleza pierde el
vínculo con ella no la va a querer no la
va a amar no le va a proteger porque no
hay un vínculo y de verdad por eso estoy
aquí porque no podemos dejar que esto
pase y hay tantas personas aquí que
pueden hacer un cambio en esto y les
cuento en anécdota hace unas semanas
estaba en el kinder con un grupo de los
niños que está haciendo un proyecto de
insectos es un grupo de niños de 3 años
y ellos se pusieron el salón de los
bichos y estando en el 1 es un día
cotidiano me acerco a ellos porque había
un niño que estaba llorando y también se
acerca a la maestra y la pregunta feliz
qué te pasa felipe qué te pasa y felipe
sigue llorando y llorando y uno como
maestra sabe cuando es un llanto del
alma
y cuando son otros llantos pero cuando
vemos entonces este niño llorando le
preguntamos de verdad que nos cuente y
nada más baja su mirada levanta la bota
que tenía puesta y decía mate un [ __ ]
como una cara de angustia que de verdad
no logra tener una empatía tan fuerte
con él y que uno sabe que esta
experiencia del niño lo va a marcar por
el resto de sus vidas por eso digo que
son conservacionistas de corazón y creo
que esto sucede cotidianamente la
maestra entonces se pone a la altura de
él y le explica que está bien sentirse
así está bien si él está triste dolido
por esto que acaba de pasar pero que fue
sin culpa y que puede estar tranquilo
devuelve a los niños el tiempo en la
naturaleza es una tarea prioritaria a
nivel político urbanístico social y
educativo todos los niños tienen derecho
al juego libre y tienen derecho a
ambientes ricos y sanos tenemos que
hacerlo
y cuando decimos devolver a los niños el
tiempo en la naturaleza no queremos que
se vuelva algo como esta imagen donde
estamos en costa rica en un país con
tanta biodiversidad y vamos a repetir
esquemas de enseñanza porque ni siquiera
está hablando de aprendizaje aquí de
enseñanza tan tradicionales tan
desconectados tan pasivos que él no es
que no es lo mismo de disfrutar la
naturaleza subiéndose a los árboles
metiéndose a los charcos que tiene todos
los beneficios que les contaba y
claramente aprender de los animales que
están en peligro de extinción de los
ciclos de la vida todo esto tienen que
aprender pero saben quiénes están en
peligro de extinción los niños en la
naturaleza los niños de la naturaleza
están en peligro de extinción y de
verdad no podemos dejar que esto pase y
con esta premisa tan fuerte fue que hace
cinco años iniciamos una red de centros
educativos para la primera infancia y
nos enfocamos en tres pilares en el
juego la comunidad y la
tura leza creíamos y creemos que es
vital que los niños y los adultos
crezcan creados de naturaleza cuando
iniciamos nos decían hippies chancletas
que no aprendían nada porque sólo
estaban jugando en el jardín pero cinco
años después tenemos evidencia de que
los niños jugando diariamente la
naturaleza son más empáticos más
recursivos más resilientes más
observadores tienen mejores relaciones
con los otros son más amantes de todos
los seres vivos y sé que muchas otras
organizaciones en costa rica lo están
haciendo también y si nos colocamos una
escala internacional actualmente hay más
de 1500 escuelas de naturaleza o
escuelas en el bosque en eeuu y europa y
como había un aumento tan grande de este
tipo de escuelas también ha habido un
aumento grande en el número de
investigaciones que se están haciendo
para sustentar estas prácticas
entonces les pregunto quiénes resuenan
con esta idea
verdad que es gracias verdad que es muy
posible now tópico que todos los niños
tengan experiencias diarias en la
naturaleza no se necesita ningún
programa y son muy bueno
solamente tiempo y la naturaleza y creer
en el vínculo fuerte de los niños con la
naturaleza y porque yo les estoy
hablando esto porque para mí la
naturaleza ha sido fuente de inspiración
de conexión me ha llenado me ha nutrido
me ha hecho ademán más creativa y me ha
aceptado como me ayuda a aceptar como
una metáfora de vida el que todos los
seres vivos no importa la forma en el
cuerpo está el tamaño son igualmente
valiosos y por eso es que quiero que
todos los niños lo vean y mi invitación
entonces final va en dos caminos o dos
líneas que ojalá sea los dos la primera
es que iniciemos con una huerta un
tierrero un espacio verde pequeño grande
ir al parque más cercano
si hacemos esto con todas las personas
que estamos aquí les aseguro que
estaríamos todos más sanos y más
conectados y ya tenemos a los mejores
aliados que son los niños sensibles
curiosos y amantes de la naturaleza y la
segunda invitación es que cuando salgan
de aquí se quiten los zapatos pongan los
pies en la tierra como los niños y
sientan ese mensaje fuerte de la madre
tierra que desde hace tiempo nos está
hablando mucho tiempo y nos pide actuar
por los niños y por la naturaleza o como
dice mi gran amigo francesco tonucci
cuidamos al niño que fuimos y no
perdamos esa mirada gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]